foreign
there's something that's been floating
around people have sent it to me in my
DMs I come in this morning to an email
from James Childs our producer guys
credit card debt it is just going
bananas okay it says as credit card debt
hits an all-time high all time
just shy of a trillion
and that's just credit card debt Jay
that's not car loans that's not student
loans that's nothing credit card debt it
says in the final three months of 2022
it's hit an all-time high delinquencies
among borrowers obviously have
accelerated I mean it makes sense we're
taking out more debt we can't afford the
debt and now we're defaulting on the
payments it says balances grew 61
billion
billion in the fourth quarter from
previous uh from the previous one to 986
billion
weight that is unbelievable it jumped
from 61 billion to 986 billion
oh so much I'm so much sorry I'm really
just taking this in because it's
ridiculous and here it says U.S
household debt jumped to a record
16.90 trillion from October through
December last year the largest quarterly
increase in 20 years as mortgage and
credit card balance is surged amid High
inflation and Rising interest rates all
right and let's just say this because
usually people are talking about the
interest rates you know on mortgages
we're talking about the housing market
yeah the interest rates on your credit
cards you guys are going up and here's
the deal and here's why we keep saying
to have that emergency fund in place and
figure out your income minus expenses
need SQL zero living on a zero-based
budget and all that because if you don't
have a plan for your money Jade you know
who has a plan the credit card companies
yes they do yes they do and they are
prepared for this you guys they are
ready to be your emergency fund yes that
on top of fees and interests and then
people can't pay the credit card bills
and and it ends up being a massive a
massive problem and so that's why
they're dangerous that's why people are
always like you don't just carry one you
know I'm like no play with snakes you're
gonna get bit like gonna get bit no no
stay away you guys and and figure out a
way that you are your emergency funds
yes and not the credit card companies
and the banks and I mean with these
interest rates Rachel the average
interest rate now 20 on credit cards on
credit cards 20 that's out of control
and here's the thing here's the the way
my brain works I'm thinking okay if
you're using your credit card to buy
daily things because you're not on a
budget because here's the thing A lot of
people are they do they keep their
credit cards there for emergencies but
then there's that sect of people who's
like okay I'm not really on a budget I'm
not really watching where my money is
going so there's this Gap at the end of
the month or Midway through the month
and I'll just use the credit cards to
float me when I go to the grocery store
or heaven forbid did when you go to a
restaurant and eat dinner right and your
your skin can I just you're scanning
your credit card for a meal that's gonna
be gone Rachel in about in about four to
six hours okay so you're literally
flushing money down the drain yes you're
flushing it down the toilet and yeah and
here's to get me started and here's the
big thing we were talking about
inflation last night at the event and
all the numbers that are coming out are
staying on average food is up yes 9.8 10
yeah and it feels more than that eggs
are up like 60 or something crazy so I
know there are certain products that are
are up more but here's the deal if you
don't have that margin yeah when this
inflation hits that needs to be your
wake-up call to say wow if I have a 10
change in something yes and it is
knocking me out to depend on credit
cards then your whole financial picture
needs to look different you guys and
that's not to shame you that's not to
right to say oh my gosh like you're so
stupid all that no no it is to be able
to say man what I am doing is not
working yeah it's a symptom of something
greater right Rachel that's right that's
exactly right and you know this Jade but
I mean we talked about this even last
night again but just the the lifestyle
that we choose to live regardless of
whether there's money in the bank or not
yeah continues continues to be at this
level and you can't just be at that
level if you don't have the money and
the and the credit cards yeah are
filling in that Gap and it's getting
people in so much trouble you guys we
are walking around in such Financial
bondage to have what to have the nice
dinner out to have the purse to and I
would say to have something with it to
have the future food and all of it but
but again if you have a 700 car payment
leaving if you have your student loan
payment leaving they have no money you
guys it's a it's the whole picture we
want you to wake up it is the whole
picture and we want you guys free from
that that's why we do this show because
we're like we want to help guide you and
show you there's such a better way to
live with your money and you're your
your true testimony to that Jade I was
just thinking about that and and I do
want to hit that because I know there
are people listening right now that are
like Jade Rachel yes you're right the
people who are spending credit card
money to buy steak bad bad bad but I'm
just I'm just trying to pay my bills I'm
trying to keep the lights on and I I
hear that because there were there was a
stretch of time uh because Sam and I had
over 20 000 in credit card debt just so
you all know and there was a stretch of
time that we weren't working uh we were
in between jobs and we when I tell you
we had close to zero dollars coming in
and we were using credit cards to try to
like fill in the gaps the worst idea
ever and we thought oh we'll just do
this it's just temporary and then you
know when we get when we get back on our
feet or when we get working again we'll
pay it all off and that is such a
vicious cycle because you're just
creating more debt for the you know
you're creating more debt that you can't
pay because you don't have any money
that's right and the best thing that you
can do when you're in a situation and
where money is low right because income
is not enough is to go out and just get
more work and and don't be too far above
any form of work yeah because I think
that there's a can I just be honest I
think some people are like no I'm too
good to work at the mall or I'm too good
to deliver pizzas or I'm too good to
take to drive Uber or whatever it is
yeah but you've got whatever it takes to
not take on debt that is noble and there
is so much dignity in saying I am going
to pay my own bills I am going to make
my own way I am not going to do this
with high interest because let me tell
you something just because you take out
High interest debt does not make you a
more interesting person all right it
just makes you more broke so it there is
dignity to that but I hear the person
who's like man I'm just trying to make
ends meet and if that's you the best
thing I can encourage you to do get on a
budget focus on the four walls and find
any work that you can just because it's
probably just temporary Prairie that's
right you just close that Gap up the
worst thing that you can do in a time
like that is depend on credit cards yeah
especially at the tune of 20 interest
all right that's right I know you keep
kind of digging into that hole and it
gets deeper and deeper and the deeper it
is the more time and the more effort on
the other end you're going to do to
climb your way out that's right so stay
keep your head above water and like
you're saying Jade yes that extra income
bringing it and there's so many side
hustles right now in life yes there is
and it's not going backwards it's
actually propelling you to go forward in
life to take control of your income so
you guys you can do this we hear stories
day in and day out with our jobs of
people that are that decide to make a
change and they're not going to be these
stats anymore of the highest credit card
debt that we've seen yet in history so
don't be a stat either don't be a stat
and if you've got credit card debt
working into your debt snowball list
them out smallest to largest make
minimum payments on all of it and throw
any and all extra money at the smallest
debt and move with speed and intensity
to get it paid off